the jurogan experience so
you were a part of this uh open letter
recently
about covet 19 where you want to get to
the bottom
of the origins of it and um this is
something we've talked about on the
podcast before and a lot of people have
been talking about it lately now that
trump's out of office it sort of freed
up the discussion
right for the longest time discussing
that in terms of like it not being
just some sort of a random mutation from
bats
and coronaviruses that it may have been
a lab leak was so taboo because
it was what trump was pushing and it's
it's so crazy that something
which is science it's a it's a
scientific
discussion and inquiry that it could be
stunted
by these political ideas when someone is
so polarizing
like trump that people just completely
want to reject
like very plausible and possible ideas
just because of him
it's exactly right i was the lead
drafter with a community of other
other people and lead scientists around
the world
of this letter and since the beginning
of last year 2020 i had maybe the
leading website in the world that was
just
stating what is the evidence about the
origins of
covet 19 particularly the evidence for a
lab leak
and the evidence is actually really
strong it's
all circumstantial evidence but we don't
have
any evidence of the other hypotheses of
where covet comes from
like these this series of jumps through
different animals
in the wild and so i for a long time
more than a year
have been saying hey we need to look
really seriously at this not because
we know or certainly i don't know for
sure that's where covet comes from but
in my view it's the most likely
hypothesis worthy of a of a
full investigation and so uh there was a
world health organization or uh
organized an independent
advisory committee and they went on a
study mission
uh to china uh in earlier this year 2021
and then they came out with a with a
they had a press event in wuhan which
was a joint press event between this
committee
and their chinese government
counterparts and in that press event
what they said was
um we don't support investigating the
possibility of a lab leak
any further but we should investigate
what seems like a
much less likely hypothesis that covets
started with
frozen foods being shipped to wuhan and
so we already had
a community of scientists and others
who'd been meeting virtually
for a while trying to say to really say
where does this come from what's the
evidence
we had academic presentations
challenging the
data trying to figure out where are the
gaps
and we looked at that we said that that
can't be right and we decided we needed
to put out an open
letter which we which we recently
released and it was covered in
newspapers
all around the world and the letter made
kind of key points one is that this is a
terrible pandemic we have to understand
where it came from
two that this uh current investigation
is not the kind of full investigation
that's needed
and three here's what a full
investigation looks like
and we call on non-governments to do it
but your point that it's been
it's been taboo for the year is exactly
right and it's just
crazy because it seems this is a really
in my
view likely possibility i can't say for
sure we should be investigating
all hypotheses not saying we can't even
look at something that that
really could be the the real story here
and it's also really unfortunate that a
lot of people are not
trusting anything that the world health
organization says anymore
because yeah the world health
organization i'm sure you saw
the uh spokesperson for the world health
organization speaking with the reporter
and he wouldn't even
mention the name taiwan did you see yeah
i know so it's
i did see that and and he logs off and
then comes back
on and then she asks him again about
taiwan's response
to covet 19 and he says well china's
done an amazing job and let's just
change subjects and yeah like the woman
keeps getting back to taiwan
and he won't recognize taiwan because
china doesn't recognize taiwan
and china has some sort of strange
i don't know what it is but there's some
sort of political influence on the world
health organization
yeah so there's a lot there so first
full disclosure i'm a member of the
world health organization international
advisory
podcast whatever i said you were exactly
right exactly
um advisory committee on human genome
editing
um and um so i'm actually a real
supporter
of the world health organization but
there's a big problem
and that problem is being realized and
we're seeing it through the course of
this
pandemic so first in the earliest days
of the
of the pandemic why was it that world
health organization
inspectors weren't able to go to wuhan
and the reason was the chinese
government wouldn't give them visas and
there was nothing the who
could do why was it that the who was
just essentially unfortunately
parroting the reporting from the chinese
government in the earliest days and and
part of that at least
is because they don't even have the
authority to have their own
surveillance network why is it
referencing your point about
taiwan that taiwan has all kinds of
expertise
in treating and responding to terrible
outbreaks like this which is why they've
only had nine
covet deaths in taiwan since the very
beginning
and why is it that the who is in this
weird
position it's in part because the who is
created by
these member states that have a lot of
influence and it's terrible
we're all suffering because taiwan
didn't have a full voice
tai on december 31 2019 taiwan declared
a national emergency on kovit that was
way before we did i wish taiwan had had
a bigger voice so
who is in a really really difficult
position because on one hand we're
asking them to investigate and
call out a member state on the other
hand their governing body
essentially is made up of member states
including china
yeah it's it's just so strange to see
scientific inquiry and analysis
pushed and manipulated by politics
well that's the whole story here i mean
that's that's unfortunately the story
of kovid is that i mean it was politics
that made it so that you could have this
outbreak and we can talk more about
where the outbreak started but wherever
it started whether it was a lab leak or
something else
if you had had a fully functioning
system if it hadn't been chinese
politics and the national institute the
national
and instinct or the natural instinct
hadn't been
to cover up to silence the
whistleblowers to give to lie
essentially to the world health
organization and the international
community
it could well have been possible to
suppress covet
in the first few weeks and we wouldn't
be having any of this so
and then it was politics that made china
again whatever the origin carry out this
massive
cover-up over the course of the last
year where they destroyed samples
eliminated or removed databases
imprisoned journalists chinese
journalists asking tough questions and
put a universal gag order
on their scientists making it impossible
for them to
speak about about any of this stuff
that's pretty incredible that that's not
really well known
yeah i mean i i've so for me it's been
more than a year and i have it on my
jamie metzel
website and i've been trying to tell
everybody
not to point fingers but to say like we
have a real
problem here unless we can just be
really honest about what's the problem
that we're facing how are we possibly
going to address it now
what is the circumstantial evidence
sorry so let me let me start from the
beginning
of this so um we know we have a long
history of these pathogenic outbreaks
and they
tend to happen uh in more tropical
parts of of china and southeast asia and
just tropical
parts of the world so when sars when
this
outbreak began um for me
i had a little bit of background one of
the reasons why
i started to get suspicious very early
on is i
recently before then been in wuhan and i
knew
wuhan wasn't a place where a bunch of
yokels are eating bats wuhan is a really
sophisticated
city it's their chicago and i knew
that they didn't have horseshoe bats in
wuhan as a matter of fact when the
outbreak
happened it was uh it was winter there
and so
there weren't bats there um and i knew
early on that this whole story of the
wet market
was a lie and as the chinese government
knew and they for many many months
pushed that
uh that story um even knowing it wasn't
true how did you know it was a lie
well big the the wuhan story because
there was a paper
that came out in the lancet in january
of 2020 and in that paper it made clear
that around a third of the first kelvid
cases
had no exposure to the wet to that
market and so if
everything started in the market you
would have expected
all of the early cases to have had a a
market exposure and so that was known
the their government knew that in
january but they didn't admit it until
may of last year
was there a common denominator for all
the people that were exposed
that's the big question now so that the
finding patient
so called patient zero that's the
essential
the essential question if the lab leak
hypothesis
is true then either patient zero
would be someone who works at one of the
these uh chinese
virology institutes probably the juan
institute of virology
or it would be someone who was exposed
to a virus that had somehow
escaped from that whether it was through
waste or in maybe an
animal escaped or or something like that
if
this the alternative story that many
scientists
believe and and could also could well be
true
that the patient zero it comes from a
series there was
animal to animal what are called
intermediate hosts it started with a bat
and then when bat to a pangolin or
whatever and eventually to a human
then you would find a patient zero
somewhere
that was that first human but if i mean
i think this is a really
important point if that's the case you'd
have to say well
what are the chances that that patient
zero
from this series of animal to animal to
human transmissions
it just happens to be it shows up in
wuhan
which is the only city in china with a
level four virology institute
that has the world's largest collection
of bat coronaviruses
that is doing gain of function research
trying to make those viruses more
virulent
particularly by making them more
able to infect human cells so it in my
mind if you
if patient zero is just somebody who had
an exposure to an animal you have a
the mathematical odds of that person
just showing up in
in wuhan would be actually kind of
absurd there's also an issue with the
actual structure of the virus itself
right
yes yeah so well this is a virus
that is um ready made for
getting to humans for the first tsars we
were able to
track how it jumped and you could see
in in retrospect how you could see it
got closer and closer and as
as the the virus mutated it became
more able uh to infect humans this virus
showed up fully able to infect humans as
a matter of fact
in the comparative studies of different
animals
including humans humans are the most
susceptible
to the sars cov2 virus so somehow you
have to explain how this virus
shows up kind of seemingly out of
nowhere in wuhan
ready for action ready to fully infect
infect humans
now this level four virology lab that's
in wuhan
what are they doing those studies for
like what is the the intent
yeah it's a really important question
because there are a lot of people who
are are saying things that i don't agree
with that oh this is some kind of
uh military bio weapon and and
say what you want about chinese
government they're not stupid
um and so for them i truly
believe if you had to ask me what's the
most likely story um
i believe that they recognized that
these kinds of
pathogens are a big threat to humans and
that we're getting more and more the
frequency these kinds of outbreaks is
growing
and rather than being behind the curve
and waiting for
for some terrible outbreak the idea was
well can we
predict how these viruses will evolve
can we get ahead of the game in
developing treatments and vaccines
for what we think may be coming and
that's what this this gain of function
research is about
and so we know um that the chinese
government that
i'm sorry the wuhan institute of
virology was doing this kind of gain of
function
research some of it was actually funded
with the united states government
money through the nih and i know you'll
get a lot of
action in the twitter sphere on on this
but um
so we know and and i truly believe that
there was
well-intentioned work trying to develop
vaccines and treatments trying to
understand how the most dangerous
pathogens might
might develop and if my hypothesis uh is
is true i think that's there was an
accident and there's a whole history of
people who were warning
saying why we're trying to prevent some
kind of future threat
but in our effort to prevent it we're
actually increasing the likelihood of it
happening
wasn't that lab cited in 2018 for safety
violations as well yes yes so the u.s
embassy sent a a small delegation they
visited
the lab and then there was there were
two cables about this
saying hey this is really dangerous
they're doing experimentation with
these dangerous coronaviruses and their
safety
protocols aren't up to snuff so there
was a lot of warning and a lot of fear
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience